John Gallagher Jr new film with Winona
Ryder gone in the night coming out now
uh the first thing I want to talk to you
about for those maybe who aren't on the
up and up little background there's a
couple that arrives in the Redwoods at a
remote cabin uh but like everyone's
worst fear no no monsters nothing like
that it's been double booked and so you
guys end up spending at least the
evening with this mysterious couple
people goes missing things happen we'll
leave it there um I would like to know
have you ever had an Airbnb double
booking and if not what would you do in
that situation oh I've never had a
double booking thank goodness uh I feel
like I am such a a wimp that I would not
do my character in the film is really
the one that talks the the couple that's
already at the cabin into letting us
stay as well uh I would probably just
say oh that's totally fine we're very
sorry I'm gonna get back in the car
drive very far away and then probably
you know complain on the app and try to
get my money back uh you know I feel
like I would just be much more practical
about it
um but I would probably be too nervous
to to share this space with you know as
beautiful as Owen Teague and Brienne Chu
are uh you know if two strange uh gen's
ears in green uh raincoats answered the
door chomping on oranges in the middle
of the night I think I might want to go
look for someplace else to stay I was
gonna say candidly your odds of survival
are probably better with that game plan
yeah exactly uh what is the worst Airbnb
or timeshare experience you've ever had
oh my gosh the worst one I gotta say
I've been really lucky knock on wood I
have been very very very very fortunate
um I've stayed in like a lot of great
places I haven't done a ton of Airbnb
Through The Years
um but I've I've only had good good luck
and now that I'm saying this out loud I
feel like this is setting me up for a
cursed Airbnb well I was gonna say my
you know better odds than the Bears you
ran into while camping a week ago right
exactly I guess we'll say that the Bears
that I saw when I was camping a few
weeks ago maybe that's my worst Airbnb
experience because the campsite is
current you have to rent it it's kind of
like an Airbnb I love it uh let's talk a
little bit about the movie you're
starting opposite Winona Ryder and man I
mean talk about a talent who's just
touched so many uh viewers over decades
from Edward Scissorhands and Dracula to
stranger things tell me a little bit
about what she brought to this role ah I
mean she's just incredible I've been
such a fan of hers since I was a kid you
know I mean I I came of age in the in
the 90s and those movies were so
important to me uh I mean her her
filmography is I think one of the most
illustrious and interesting of almost
any actor in Hollywood that I can think
of that run from like you know 87 for
starting with like Lucas and Beetlejuice
going all the way to you know a girl
interrupted I mean she's had this
incredible run and now to be you know uh
back in the Limelight in such a way with
stranger things I was thrilled when I
got this grip to be because I found out
that she was aware of my work and that
she had kind of signed off on me being
cast in this role I couldn't believe
that she knew who I was and she's just a
dream I mean they they say you know be
be careful when you meet your Idols
because they somehow might let you down
or disappoint you and I can I can really
say that was not at all the case with
Winona I mean she was everything I kind
of dreamed that she would be and Beyond
I mean just such a sweet and tender Soul
a real genuine artist and a real
kind-hearted person and we just had a
blast on set I mean I was just like
telling her I was like tell me please
tell me more stories about working on
Dracula tell me more stories about
working with Tim Burton I was just like
a totally uh captive audience and she
was kind enough to tell me some great
tales about her life and her career you
know I love that I was gonna add I
wanted to kind of dig into her
filmography a bit but I'm like who knows
maybe John hasn't seen a lot of the
movies I don't want to set him up for
failure but I mean let's bring it back
um for the uninitiated maybe some
younger viewers those gen zeers that you
were complaining about earlier
um well give me like the Winona Ryder
starter pack three movies from her
career prayer that everyone should see
to kind of get familiar with okay I
think I would start I would think I
would say uh Heather's you know I think
that's such a kind of a a rival I mean
she had already been making lots of
films but I feel like that's been a
rival into into kind of a next phase of
a more adult phase of her career she's
so good and so funny in that and it's
such a twisted and interesting you know
satire
um I would definitely say Reality Bites
just because I think that that's such a
fun film to watch all those performances
you've got you know just blistering
performances from her and Ethan Hawke
and then young Janine Garofalo and young
Steve Zahn and then it's directed by Ben
Stiller and his work is so impressive in
it
um and then the one that's kind of
jumping out to me after that is Edward
Scissorhands because it's just such a
such a beautiful film and such a Gothic
strange fairy tale and still such a
moving Love Story uh you know I mean oh
my God hold me I can't whoa when that
line comes up at the end I mean man you
know that's just uh water works for me
that one always gets me always makes me
cry I love it I do want to top and tail
and finish up on some more gone to the
night stuff so we'll come back to it I
don't want to talk a little bit about
your career
um as a Green Day obsessive was yet to
see them live any memorable stories from
your time on doing American Idiot on
Broadway oh my gosh yeah that's one of
the things I remember the most is that
um uh so Green Day sometimes plays in
this they have this side band called The
Foxborough hot tubs it's kind of like a
uh just like a side project it's kind of
like a glorified bar band they do a lot
of covers and they play these kind of
garage songs that sound like The Kinks
or the sonics and uh they don't play as
much anymore as they used to but there
was a stretch there where they would
play tiny clubs and I remember one night
it was a Sunday night we were doing
American Idiot on Broadway and they
played a Sunday night show at this club
the Bowery Electric in New York City
which only holds a couple hundred people
and they just cram The Place full of
first come first serve Green Day fans
and they played like a three and half
hour set people were covered in beer
like people were like throwing people
were dousing themselves in Pabst Blue
Ribbon I got yanked up on stage to sing
with Billy Joe a couple times
um it was just one of those I was stage
diving at the end of the night gets a
little fuzzy for me because I over
served myself
um but it was like one of the most rock
and roll fun nights I think I've ever
had and it all happened because you know
Green Day was so generous with uh
letting us into their Social Circle
while we were doing that show what a
story to talk about taking karaoke to
the next level truly absolutely yeah you
know Green Day very much
anti-establishment critical of the
oversaturation of media
um I'm sure you could ask about The
Newsroom all the time how do you think
that show would sort of look if they
were to sort of updated for 2022. I you
know I thought of this uh because you
know we were kind of right on this it
was there was kind of a Changing of the
Guard you know at the time that that
show aired when you think about it it
started airing 10 years ago this summer
with which is I don't know where the
time went but it was before streaming it
was really right before everything went
kind of through into the stratosphere
with Twitter and social media and the
idea of breaking news mostly coming from
online Outlets
um if you did it now I I have no idea
what it would look like or how it would
seem you know I I caught a clip of it
recently online and and you know I'm not
I'm not sliding the show in any sense
because I'm very proud of it but it's
it's funny how dated it already seems
just with just a decade of time elapsing
you know which I think just speaks to
how fast things move these days it's
just like they're we're you know
technology is kind of advancing and
developing almost faster than we can get
used to it
um so if you were to do it now I feel
like it would I don't know it would be
probably like a multimedia show like
you'd watch part of it on TV and then
you'd log into a streaming site and then
you'd finish the episode on your phone
or something and then you log into your
your mental algorithm to see the season
finale it uh mixed media I don't know
augmented reality through the contact
lenses exactly uh any interest in in
doing a reboot if it were to ever
materialize oh sure man I mean if they
if that if that were to be in the car
it's it would be it would be an
interesting thing because you know uh I
think when we were doing that uh I think
a lot of people were like oh this is a
Fantastical version of how the news
works and it is a little bit because
Aaron does operate in a certain
heightened reality but uh that was
before the Trump era and you know even
when we were doing that show I think
nobody knew it was going to get as crazy
as it got uh in terms of the the inter
meshing of politics in the media so I'm
sure Aaron would have some very
interesting things to say about it now
any updates that you can get yourself in
trouble by sharing I wish I haven't
talked to anyone from the show in a
while I'm just waiting for my phone to
ring
well fingers crossed I mean I think it'd
be uh you know we could we could do a
little more prediction about what's to
come in the next 10 20 years exactly the
last thing before we finish up on some
rapid fire if time permits on your end
um Westworld where you know season four
just launched we got season five the
final season right on the way
um obviously it's not done yet and that
final season is as soon as other shows
can be a big deal uh how do you think
people will look back on Westworld when
it's all said and done I think it was
such a game changer of a show uh you
know Jonathan Nolan and and Lisa Joy I
mean they make every single episode of
that show and they're only 60 minutes
but they make them as if they were a
two-hour you know major motion picture
you know I think Jonathan's work with
his brother Christopher obviously some
people may have heard of him uh you know
has has given him this like sharp
toolkit for filmmaking and especially
visual storytelling I mean the scope of
that show you know it's an HBO show but
when I sit walked onto the set it really
was like walking on to like a big giant
big budget Motion Picture kind of Studio
set it was really impressive and then
they get all this work done and you know
TV days are kind of hard to make because
you've got to film it pretty quick you
only have a couple weeks to film every
episode so they just get so much work
done I think the show is going to be
looked back on as something that really
that in Game of Thrones it really
elevated what's possible with uh with TV
and streaming
um you've done a lot of rare thriller
horror-esque films obviously gone on the
night time Cloverfield Lane personal
favorite of mine abandoned just came out
as well
um are there any sort of tips or tricks
that directors and production teams can
use to sort of create that sense of
dread on you know behind the scenes
uh and I think so much of it really it
sounds a little cliched but so much of
it starts really with what's on the page
the script if you have like a
well-written like scary script uh and
then you have like a Visionary behind
the camera
um I think everything else kind of falls
into place and if you get a good cast
together like a good Ensemble everybody
kind of just knows how to drop in to
that world I definitely felt that on
Cloverfield the script was just so good
that everybody just kind of knew what to
do with it and then we had this
beautiful set and we just got lost in
and then that same thing on hush you
know I worked with Mike Flanagan before
you know that was first film that went
to Netflix and then now he's the king of
the Netflix limited horror series and
it's just amazing same thing that script
I couldn't put it down you know it was
so so well written and then this gone in
the night too like I started reading it
and I I couldn't I didn't stop until I
was finished and to me that's like the
real Telltale sign of a good thriller is
if you if you can't put it down if you
if you want to put it down and you know
go get another cup of coffee or or you
know turn the TV on or check your
Instagram or whatever usually it means
that it doesn't quite have a hook but uh
this one really grabbed me